dave is it true that a that after
nirvana pearl jam
asked you to be their drummer and tom
petty asked you to be their drummer and
you turned them down
petty yes pearl jam no i don't know
where the pearl jam thing came from
um i you know friends with those guys
like we knew each other we were when i
was living in seattle at the time so i
knew those guys but they never called
and asked me to play drums with them i
played
i jammed with them once on stage in like
australia or something like that but no
they didn't they didn't call but petty
did i did saturday night live with tom
petty
and we had so much fun and we all got
along so well
i was like yeah wait why be me
like i mean he could get like a
world-class drummer like any dude
and so but then i came down and jammed
and i mean honestly
you must have hung out with him or met
him before never
really yeah i had an opportunity to
interview him and we were going to do it
like kind of like this over over a
camera
and at the time i was like no no no i'm
gonna wait for tom petty to come in the
studio
and i waited too long because then i
never got to interview him
some [ __ ] move he was he was
very cool and very like low-key
down-to-earth
just really really cool did you take it
seriously when he said to you hey i want
you to be my drummer permanently i mean
you know we had one we had we played snl
and afterwards he basically
he was like man that was good be shame
if that's the only time we do it sort of
thing and then he called me at home
and he's like well look if you want
here's how we do it
like you get your own bus and we don't
tour too hard and blah blah blah and
he was um kind of explaining like you
know if you're into it
come out and let's do it for a little
while but i had just started doing this
thing
and i just felt weird about just going
right back to the drums because it would
have just reminded me of being in
nirvana it would have been sad
for me personally just it would have
been an emotional thing to be behind the
drum
set every night and not have kurt there
so i was like nah [ __ ] it i'm going to
try this other thing